come on vote more like
come on body jessica simpson looks
healthy
fit and fabulous
[Music]
the singer turned fashion mogul posted
this selfie to her instagram wednesday
showing off her hard work in the gym of
course she's rocking a super cute
tie-dye fit from her jessica simpson
collection
but all eyes are on her fit figure
major ab definition toned thighs and cut
calves
but for jess she says it's all about
being healthy physically
and mentally she explained in the
caption that she woke up early before
her kids to get her steps in and spend
some time alone
quote move move move for your own mental
health
nobody's telling me what to wear how to
look
you know and um how to be because i just
know now
eti sat down with the blonde beauty in
january while promoting her memoir open
book she candidly addressed her journey
with health and fitness after having her
third
child daughter birdie in march 2019
i mean the body image pressures
they never go away because so many
people
focus on it i mean people think right
now like oh she snapped back
i did not snap back i i wish i just
snapped back
but i work my butt off to get in
to shape and to like stay on a health
kick
you know and this time i'm not drinking
so
that was a lot of calories you know
jessica also worked with celebrity
trainer harley pasternak
who shared her top three tips for living
her healthiest life
number one walk hit at least 12 000
steps a day
number two go to bed a few minutes early
and number three
let's get sugar out of your diet get
sugar out and take back control
clearly jess is not only looking great
she's feeling great
enjoying extra time with her family as
they self-isolate at home amid the
coronavirus pandemic
they've been cooking cleaning swimming
and even getting back to jessica's roots
singing
this little
i'm gonna let it shine
let it shine let it
shine let it shine
you